hi I'm reto Meier Google developer
advocate today I learned how to get one
terabyte of data processed with Google
bigquery each month at no cost
without entering a credit card if you're
excited to explore the bigquery public
data sets like these but you're not
excited about paying for it there's
great news B query lets you process a
terabyte of data every month at no cost
getting started is quick and easy and
you don't even need to enter your credit
card details we'll get started by
navigating the docks to the bigquery web
UI or you can go directly to bigquery
cloud or Google calm at this point
you'll need to sign in using a Google
account once you signed in continue to
bigquery we'll start by creating a new
project if it's our first one
that means first reading and accepting
the Terms of Service for the Google
cloud platform eventually we'll want to
take advantage of the free trial but
let's dismiss it for now and create our
project you can share data and queries
from bigquery so make sure you give your
project a good name once the projects
ready we'll get a notification click
that and it'll be selected as our active
project we're now done and we can start
running queries I'm also going to enable
the bigquery API here so that I can run
programmatic queries later before I run
some queries let's take a quick peek at
our billing tab as you can see this is a
new project so there's no billing
instrument associated with it now when
we head back to the bigquery web UI we
get the bigquery web UI let's start by
querying the usa names database to make
sure we can use that free quota to query
the public data sets we query charges
for queries using one metric the number
of bytes process rounded to the nearest
Meg with a 10 Meg minimum per table
reference and data processed if you open
the query validator you can see the
number of bytes that will be processed
by running the query you have entered
this is calculated as the total data
processed for the columns you select
even if you set an explicit limit so
it's much more important to reduce the
number of columns you process than the
number of rows you return when the query
returns the number of bytes processed is
displayed here and your query log shows
the exact number of billable bytes note
that you can preview
full results of every table using the
preview button so you rarely need to
select start on a table when you're
comfortable with using bigquery we can
add a billing account you still get a
free terabyte each month but you also
get to upload your own data in addition
to queries beyond the first terabyte
bigquery also charges you to store data
and stream inserts but loading data or
copying exporting or performing metadata
operations like lists update and delete
aren't charged if you're new to Google
cloud platform you can take advantage of
the free trial it will let you continue
experimenting with bigquery still at no
cost pricing page here has details on
exactly how bigquery calculates the cost
of each query based on the types of data
in each column yura have switched to an
account with billing enabled so I can
create a new data set and query some of
my own data
here I'm using data kept externally on
Google Drive rather than storing it
within bigquery
when you need more than a terabyte in a
month you're charged at a rate of five
dollars per terabyte you and you pay for
what you use though and it's rounded to
the nearest megabyte so that works out
to about half a cent per gig and note
that you can set cost controls so that
once your credit card has been added you
don't have any unfortunate surprises
tune in each week to learn more bigquery
tips and tricks for now use your
terabyte of processing to analyze your
own data or use our public datasets to
understand the world and create cool
visualizations and don't forget to share
them with us using the today I learned
with bigquery hashtag and of course
subscribe to our Channel and follow our
blog to learn something new with
bigquery